JEFF POSNICK: Thanks for coming
out today to our talk
on the embeddable YouTube
upload widget.
So I'm Jeff Posnick.
I'm from the YouTube API
developer relations team based
in New York City.
And joining me today is Eric
Lundberg, who is the engineer
responsible for the YouTube
embeddable upload widget.
And we're really psyched
to be presenting today.
So before I get into any more
details, I wanted to make it
very clear that what we're
showing today is a preview of
things that we will be releasing
to the general
developer community hopefully
very soon now.
So we don't have any actual URLs
or docs that you could go
off and try right
away right now.
But we're going to be showing
you some things that we hope
to make available very soon.
I'm going to give an overview
of what we're going to be
covering today.
Eric's going to start by talking
about what exactly
this embeddable upload
widget is.
He's going to demonstrate an
example integration that we
had with one of our trusted,
tester, prerelease partners,
Formspring, show you how they're
using the widget
within their site.
He's going to go into more
detail about how he wrote the
widget, some pretty cool
JavaScript stuff that he was
doing, and just how
he built it.
And then he's going to talk
about how you could use the
widget on your own site.
I'm going to go at that point
into a case study about our
featured integration of the
widget in a new project that
we're calling YouTube
Direct Lite.
And at that point we'll have
some time at the end for
questions and hopefully some
answers that we can provide.
So with that, I'm going to
pass things over to Eric.
ERIC LUNDBERG: Thanks, Jeff.
So the YouTube embeddable upload
widget is simply a way
for any website to support
uploads directly to YouTube
from their own website without
leaving that website.
And just like with uploads on
YouTube.com, normal uploads,
the videos that the user uploads
belong to that user.
However, additionally, the
host website can see the
videos that come through the
widget and keep a list of
those videos for whatever
reason they'd like to.
And the widget has
two main modes.
You can either record on the fly
using the user's webcam,
if they have a webcam.
Or the user can select the file
from their computer and
upload it just like with the
uploads on the website today.
So why did we build it?
First of all, it was one of the
most requested things on
our public issue tracker,
on our developer forum.
And additionally, we wanted a
solution, a video upload API
solution that allows external
uploads with really minimal
integration effort.
There are a few options today
with JavaScript, some server
side deployments.
But none of them are as simple
as we think this will be.
And we really see two main
use cases for this.
First of all, a web community,
a self-contained web
community, can maintain a list
of videos that belong to them
that were uploaded by the
members of that community.
And also a blog or a new site
can post an article and
solicit video responses from
that article directly from the
article itself just like
a user would go
and type a text comment.
Have it appear on the site.
They can solicit a video comment
and then just embed
that video right in their
comment stream.
The API to the widget looks very
similar to what we have
today for the iframe player.
There are two main
ways to use it.
First, you can just
simply copy and
paste this HTML snippet.
Just put the iframe directly
in your HTML.
Give it some basic parameters,
width and height, and it
should just work.
However, if you want to get a
little bit more advanced, you
can use the JavaScript
API that we provide.
And you do that by, as you can
see at the very bottom,
loading a script from
YouTube.com.
And that script gives you the
symbols that you need to
create a widget, specifically
yt.upload widget.
You call that constructor with
the name of the DOM element
that you want to replace.
And again some parameters,
here you have width.
We pass in width.
The height is determined
for us.
We pass in some events.
In this example,
onUploadsuccess.
And that onUploadsuccess
function will be called
anytime a user successfully
uploads a video to YouTube
through the widget
on your site.
Before I get too much into the
technical details, I want to
show you an example integration
that one of our
partners, Formspring, put
together and allowed us to
show at I/O today.
Formspring is a platform
for online discussions.
It's primarily a question
and answer forum.
A user can post a question and
other users can respond.
Or a user can just say,
I am such and
such, ask me anything.
And users post them questions
and then they
have to answer them.
And today there are two
main ways of posting
questions and answers.
Basically, just text
and images.
But this embeddable upload
widget now allows the
opportunity for video
responses.
And let me just show you
what that looks like.
First of all, let me just say
this is a staging version of
their website.
So there may be a few
issues with it.
But we should be able to show
you how our widget looks like
embedded on their page.
So it looks like it's working.
Here's a number of questions
and answers
that are here already.
I can just go to the top here,
ask my friends a question.
I could type something here.
I could post an image.
But what I'm going to do is
click on this little movie
icon and record a webcam video
question for my users.
So first, Flash comes up and
asks me to set some settings
and asked me, do I want to allow
YouTube to access my
camera and microphone.
I say yes.
And this is what I have.
So I'm just going to ask
my friends a question.
How are you enjoying
I/O today?
Now I can play that back.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-How are you enjoying
I/O today?
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
ERIC LUNDBERG: And if I'm happy
with it I can just go
right to upload.
And as you can see at the top
there, it's put a link to that
video right into the
host widget here.
And I can ask that question.
The way they get that video
link is again through that
onUploadSuccess callback that
I showed you earlier.
Once I upload the video, the
host site sees that video ID
and can create the video link.
And just to show you how simple
this is, here I've
actually taken the widget and
embedded it directly into our
HTML slides.
And it looks pretty much
the same here.
There's also an option to
upload video files.
I can select the file from my
hard drive and upload that.
So now I'm going to go into a
bit of a deep dive on the
technical implementation.
Talk a bit about how we
built it and what
technologies are involved.
First, just a high
level overview of
what this looks like.
You have the web browser which
runs on the user's computer.
And in their web browser they've
loaded your website.
And in your website
you have your own
JavaScript and some HTML.
You've also embedded a script
that I've showed you earlier
which loads the upload widget
symbols from YouTube.com.
And you use that script to
create the upload widget which
is shown here in blue.
And the widget can talk
to your JavaScript.
I'll go into that a
bit more later.
And it also talks to YouTube
primarily by uploading the
actual videos to YouTube.
Let me talk first just a little
bit about the API
that's available.
When this is ready we'll publish
some complete docs,
but just to give you
a quick overview.
You have a set of callbacks,
onApiReady, which is triggered
the first time the widget loads
and the JavaScript API
is available.
onUploadSuccess, which fires
anytime a video is
successfully uploaded
to YouTube.
onProcessingComplete, which
happens when that video is
viewable and for example you
could take that callback and
at that point embed a iframe
player in your website.
onVideoIDAvailable just means
that the YouTube video ID, the
public video ID, is available.
onStateChange happens anytime
that the webcam widget changes
state, maybe from playback,
to recording, to idle.
And onWebcamCancel happens if
the user clicks that cancel
button that I showed you, that
takes them back to the main
initial page that presents the
webcam or file options.
And in addition to
these callbacks
we have some commands.
Currently these commands need
to be invoked during the
onApiReady callback due
to timing issues.
And they basically boil down
to setting metadata on the
videos that are uploaded.
You can set currently
description, keywords, and the
actual title of the video.
Our upload servers look-- we use
the same servers that we
use for regular file uploads.
The whole upload flow looks
very similar to the way
uploads on My Videos Upload
look like today.
Those upload servers run
on upload.YouTube.com.
And we share quite a bit of the
JavaScript with the normal
My Videos Upload site.
These file uploads happen
via XHR when it's
available using PUT.
We use a resumable protocol.
So if the user starts to upload
a file and then closes
their web browser, they can come
back later, select that
file again, and the upload
will just continue
where it left off.
And we do actually use CORS,
Cross-origin resource sharing,
to communicate cross
from [? www ?]
to upload when it's available
in the browser.
And on non-XHR browsers
we have a
couple of other options.
For IE, we use Silverlight
if it's installed.
Or for browsers that have
neither XHR nor Silverlight
support, we'll just do
a simple HTTP post.
For the webcam uploads we use a
protocol called RTMP, which
stands for Real Time
Messaging Protocol.
It was developed by Adobe.
It was originally proprietary,
but now it's public.
The spec is public and
Google has its own
implementation of that.
And because the initial version
of the webcam really
actually requires Flash,
we don't yet
have a full HTML solution.
Using RTMP was very convenient
because the Flash plug-in
itself and the Flash API
supports RTMP natively.
And we actually use the same
service for RTMP as we do for
the file uploads.
On the client side, the widget
is just an iframe.
It's an iframe which loads its
contents from the YouTube
servlet, HTML, JavaScript,
CSS.
And it implements a core
functionality of uploads,
basically what you have on My
Videos Upload minus some of
the advanced metadata editing
features which the user can
still do later on the
website itself.
And we actually share the
camera SWF with Google+.
Google+ has its own webcam
application that just runs on
the Google+ website.
It's not an embeddable thing.
And it allows someone to create
a webcam video and post
that to their Google+ stream.
We use the same code there.
And thanks to HTML5 technology,
specifically
something called postMessage,
the iframe widget and the
window that's embedding it can
communicate with each other to
a limited extent.
PostMessage has been
around for quite a
while in most browsers.
It's in the most recent version
of every major browser.
Specifically, it has existed
since these versions that are
listed here.
And what it does is it allows
two windows that are running
on different domains to talk to
each other by standardizing
all communication
as JSON data.
You pass an object to it and
that object gets converted to
JSON data and that JSON data
arrives at the other window.
And what this looks like
is-- you can see here--
on the sender side, the
sender has a reference
to the other window.
And it just calls postMessage
on that window.
It passes the message,
which is an object.
And it can also specify
a targetOrigin.
And I'll explain a bit more
about that later.
The receiver, just as an event
listener for a special event
called message, and it supplies
a receiveMessage
callback which handles these
postMessages as they come in.
And the nice thing for anyone
who's using the API, the
widget API, is that they don't
need to implement this
themselves.
The API has both a host-side and
a YouTube-side component,
and those pieces handle
the postMessage
communication for you.
All the API user needs to do is
supply some callbacks that
are run when different
postMessages happen.
Here's just a quick illustration
of what this
looks like, very simple.
You have Window A, let's
say that is our iframe.
And when it loads, for example,
it sends that on
ApiReady callback to the host
window via postMessage.
That message arrives at the
other window and is processed
just like any other
JavaScript event.
It goes into an event queue and
those events are processed
serially and single-threadedly.
One thing that's kind of nice
about postMessage is that it
standardizes this cross-window
communication as just simple
event handling.
And this is nice because in
general, browsers handle event
handling more consistently
than just generic
cross-window scripting.
However, this can
be challenging.
In some cases, like I said
during the onApiReady
callback, the host and the
iframe need to synchronize a
little bit and agree on what
metadata to set on the video.
The way we handle this is by
sending another event from the
host-side portion of that
JavaScript API.
It says now the host is ready.
And this just happens when that
callback finishes running.
The way we authenticate the user
using the widget is just
the same as with any other
servlet that's running on
YouTube.com.
Because the iframe runs on
YouTube.com it has access to
the YouTube cookie.
And if the user isn't
logged in we
still display the widget.
But when the user clicks on a
button that requires them to
use a feature like the
webcam or a file
upload we launch a pop-up.
And that pop-up prompts them
to log into Google.
And it runs in a separate
window.
The user can see that they're
logging into Google.
They're not logging
into your website.
And then once that happens the
widget has access to their
cookie and all their
information.
However, the hosting window does
not have access to that
information because of the
same-origin-policy.
There's two windows running on
different domains and that
information isn't shared.
And as usual, when a user
uploads a video to YouTube or
when an user uses this widget,
they're only authorized to
upload to their own channel.
There's also some authentication
that happens
between the windows
themselves.
This is mostly handled for
us by the browser.
To explain how this happens let
me just show you what a
postMessage contains.
It contains the data, which is
the JSON data, that comes from
the other window.
The origin, which is populated
by the browser, it indicates
which domain sent
the postMessage.
And the source window
which is just a
reference to that window.
So the receiving window can then
send postMessages back to
the sender.
And because this origin is
provided for us we don't need
to authenticate the window.
The browser tells
us who it is.
We just need to authorize
that window.
And as I mentioned
before, there's a
targetOrigin parameter.
When you send a postMessage,
the sender can tell the
browser this message can
only be received by
the following domain.
Specifically in the widget, the
host-side portion of the
API will only exchange
messages to or from
YouTube.com.
And the widget, the iframe side
of that API, only listens
to messages from the domain
that actually loaded it.
And this prevents a third window
from intercepting or
forging communication between
your site and YouTube.com.
And in addition, each widget
has its own unique ID.
So if you embed multiple widgets
on your website, the
messages should just be
delivered to the right place.
And this is handled
again by the API.
There's a lot that we
want to improve
with this going forward.
First and foremost, we want to
support something called
getUserMedia which is part
of the HTML5 spec.
It's in WebRTC, so it's
behind a flag in the
latest Chrome Canary.
And what this is, is its just
an interface getting webcam
data, media streams,
using pure HTML.
So it's in Chrome Canary.
It's in the latest
version of Opera.
It's in IE10.
We haven't implemented anything
yet for the widget
but we're working on it.
The biggest blocker right now
for us is just finding a way
to take that media stream and
create an actual video file.
But the good news is that once
we figure out all the issues
here we can just drop it into
the widget and the host site
doesn't need to worry
about it.
The API should look the same.
Mobile is also still very
much a work in progress.
The bad news is that there is
no in-browser application.
Again for that you need
getUserMedia.
That's under development
in several browsers.
Opera Mobile 12 has an
implementation, the first and
only implementation.
The good news is today
though that this
sort of works in Android.
If the user loads the widget
on their Android phone and
they select the file upload,
the Android will give you a
few options.
One of those options
is to create a
file using the camcorder.
And then if you choose that
option you just go out to the
camcorder, record your
video, hit OK.
That video becomes a file and
goes to YouTube as a normal
file upload.
We also want to support
developer tags and integrate
with the API in a more
generic way.
One of the really core use cases
with this widget, as I
mentioned before, is for the
site that's using the widget
to be able to track all
the uploads that come
through that widget.
And this is possible today
in a way using these
onUploadSuccess callbacks.
These callbacks can be faked
locally, however.
Just if the user finds your
JavaScript handler and calls
that, then you can fake
onUploadSuccess events.
You can also attach a custom
keyword to the video that will
get saved to the video.
The user can later go and remove
it, but that's another
way to track these videos.
You can even go back later and
query for videos by keyword
and collect any videos that
you may have missed.
But really the long-term
solution here, in our mind, is
to support this with
developer tags.
Which means that we need to
change our backends to upload
videos through the API.
And then those developer tags,
custom tags that you specify
when you've registered a
developer key already, you can
go and search for any video
that was tagged with that
developer tag.
And supporting this also means
that we need to support OAuth
2 as an alternative to the
cookie auth scheme that I
mentioned before.
And in fact if you use the
developer tags your users
would need to sign in OAuth
instead of cookie auth.
So now I'm going to turn it over
to Jeff and he's going to
show you a case study called
YouTube Direct Lite that we
are working on now.
And he'll explain more
about what that is.
JEFF POSNICK: Thanks
so much Eric.
So I wanted to talk about a
little bit of the motivation
behind YouTube Direct Lite.
The webcam upload widget is
great and other means of
soliciting videos on your
website is great.
But there's a problem of
how you curate them.
And that gets into a
little bit of what
Eric was talking about.
There's manual ways of looking
for videos that have been
uploaded using a specific
tag or using
that callback handler.
But that kind of involves
writing
some custom code yourself.
You might be just somebody who's
running a website and
not necessarily much
of a developer.
And it would be really nice if
there were a platform that's
already written that would
provide some of that
functionality with you while
integrating the newest things
that we're offering.
So that's what we consider
YouTube Direct Lite to be.
It makes it easy to moderate
video submissions.
And you don't have to use the
API that Eric was talking
about directly.
YouTube Direct Lite will handle
all the technical
details for you and you just
need to add YouTube Direct
Lite to your website.
Before I talk much more about
YouTube Direct Lite, I wanted
to talk about the Legacy YouTube
Direct platform.
Not surprisingly, there's
YouTube Direct Lite, chances
are there was a YouTube
Direct.
There still is.
It's an open source platform
for soliciting videos from
your website's community.
And we've actually seen a number
of news organizations,
such as the New York Times
who have used it for the
Reflections on 9/11 project,
or San Francisco's ABC7
uReport project, a screenshot
of which you can see down
here, integrate with YouTube
Direct in the past.
And we're really excited about
those types of integrations
and we hope to see more moving
forward, especially with the
YouTube Direct Lite now
available or available soon.
So the way YouTube Direct
works is that videos are
uploaded into individual users'
accounts, which is our
recommended best practice.
This is actually really
important.
We don't recommend that websites
or other online
communities set up systems that
allow users of their site
to upload videos into
one master account.
That invites a whole
bunch of problems.
And we have a blog post on our
YouTube API blog that talks a
little bit more about why
that's not a good idea.
So both YouTube Direct and
YouTube Direct Lite, follow
that best practice.
These videos will live
in the YouTube
accounts of your users.
And you can then go and curate
them and moderate them a bit.
And the act of approving a video
that's been submitted
will simply add it to a playlist
that lives in the
master accounts.
That's the way of featuring the
submissions that you want
to particularly highlight.
So YouTube Direct was built
using Java App Engine.
Java App Engine is great
platform, but it requires a
decent amount of expertise to
get your YouTube Direct
instance up and running
and to maintain it.
And you need to have familiarity
with a bunch of
different things, not only
Java and App Engine but
Eclipse and how you properly
deploy this platform.
So it ended up being a bit of
a hassle for a lot of our
potential integrators.
And we really have been, for a
while now, been looking for an
easier solution for
getting set up.
So that's YouTube Direct.
YouTube Direct does happen to
support mobile submissions, a
dedicated Android
and iOS client.
Those are open source.
And actually the whole YouTube
Direct and YouTube Direct Lite
platforms are open
source as well.
And one of the things that we've
heard a lot from YouTube
Direct users, particularly
from the community and in
general, as Eric mentioned this
is one of our top open
issue tracker requests,
is support for webcam
submissions.
It's a very obvious
integration.
It's great if you are allowing
people to upload videos from
their hard drive, but let's say
somebody wants to record a
video right on the spot in
response to an article that
you posted.
So integrating with the webcam
upload widget is a really huge
deal for the YouTube
Direct platform.
So that was more details about
the Legacy platform.
I want to talk about the rewrite
and what went into
creating YouTube Direct Lite.
So it's a complete rewrite
of the platform.
We pretty much rethought this
from the ground up.
And I'm the primary engineer
who's been working on it.
The focus has been on
modernizing the codebase.
It's three-years old code.
It's not necessarily some of
the code that I'm the most
proud of in the YouTube Direct
platforms so we wanted to
write something that
was a little bit
more modern and fresh.
And incorporate these new
features that people have been
asking about for awhile
including webcam submissions.
And more than anything else,
just drastically
simplifying the setup.
If I run a website and I want to
start using YouTube Direct
Lite, I really want that to
be as easy as possible.
I don't want to go and deploy
things in Java App Engine.
I don't want to do
anything else.
So one of the things that makes
it possible for this to
be so simple is that the code
is written in client-side
HTML, CSS, and JavaScript.
There is no Java code
running on a server.
There's no Python code
And this is only something
that's recently possible.
So we wanted to do this for
awhile, but we actually could
not do that until we rolled out
a cross-origin resource
sharing, or CORS support
in the YouTube API.
And this means that we could
write JavaScript code, have it
run on a webpage, and that
JavaScript code could make
calls directly to our YouTube
API servers without having to
have an intermediary server
proxying those requests.
So this again means no server
deployment is strictly required.
You don't have to run anything
off your own if
you don't want to.
But there is an option for those
who do you want a little
bit more customization.
If you want complete control
over the user interface, you
can download the code or
check out the code.
You can customize it and deploy
it locally on your
existing web server.
And this is actually what we're
going to ask folks to do
once it's available.
If you happen to be on a very
large website and you know
that you get a lot of traffic,
hosting the code yourself is
probably the best
solution here.
It's very simple.
You're just checking out HTML,
JavaScript, and CSS files and
you can put it anywhere on
your existing web server,
anywhere that's publicly
accessible.
And if you take that approach
you do have complete control
over the user interface.
It's fairly simple to customize
the CSS to meet the
rest of the design of
your website so
everything fits together.
And we are expecting folks
to want to do that.
But there's another group of
folks who really just wants to
make this as simple as possible,
drop one thing on
their webpage and automatically
support YouTube
Direct Lite submissions.
And we're going to be able
to make that possible.
You'll just put on a specific
iframe tag on your page, on
any existing webpage.
The source will point to a
centrally hosted YouTube
Direct Lite script.
You'll just have to specify the
playlist ID that you're
interested in soliciting
submissions for.
And you customize it a little
bit in terms of width and
height, but you really don't
have too much control over it.
So this is supposed to be
as simple as possible.
And it's in fact so simple that
I could do this right on
our HTML slide deck.
So what you're seeing right
now is an initial YouTube
Direct Lite screen.
Because I'm in a Chrome
incognito window right now I'm
not logged into this instance
of YouTube Direct so I can
take you through
the login flow.
So what this is actually
using is OAuth 2.
And OAuth 2 is our recommended
way of handling authorization
and authentication whenever
you're doing anything using
the YouTube API, or really
any Google APIs.
So it will present your end-user
with a screen right
over here where they see
specifically what the name of
this application is, which
access this application is
requesting.
In this case it wants to view
and manage my videos and view
and manage my YouTube
activity.
And it gives me as the user a
chance to explicitly say,
allow access, before it
can act on my behalf.
So I'm going to do that.
And I'm going to be taken back
to the screen which has now,
that I've logged in,
has populated
with my YouTube videos.
So these are some videos that
already in my account.
And you'll see there's three
different modes for submitting
videos for YouTube
Direct Lite.
So you have Eric a little bit
earlier recording this video
from the webcam.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
How are you enjoying
I/O today?
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
JEFF POSNICK: Yes, that ended up
in my YouTube account which
is not a best practice,
but I'll let it slide.
So you can take any existing
video that's already in your
account and click the
submit video button.
And it will end up being
submitted to that particular
instance of YouTube
Direct Lite.
I'll talk a little bit more
about it later but this
basically means is that it's
associated with a specific
playlist for future
moderation.
So the video still lives, in
this case, this Jeff Posnick
test account.
It's not like it gets copied
over or anything like that.
We're simply changing the
metadata of that video to let
YouTube Direct Lite know that,
that video has been submitted.
So there's two other
tabs up here.
We do just have an old style
upload form that lets you put
in title, description and
a category for a video.
Choose a local video file that's
already recorded and
saved on your hard drive and
submit that to YouTube.
There are ways of customizing
YouTube Direct Lite so that
hard code specific titles are
descriptions so you have
control over what gets displayed
in this form.
And finally, we have the webcam
widget over here which
you've seen already.
So I wanted to talk
more about the
administrative side of things.
So you have your YouTube Direct
Lite instance on your
web page and you want to see
what's been submitted.
You don't want this
to be a black box.
So I just have to click that
login button again but because
I've previously authorized
it, it will take me
right into the screen.
And you'll see in the initial
administration screen is a
list of all the playlists that
are in your YouTube account.
So again think of this as me
looking at a master account at
this point even though it's
the same account I showed
before as part of the clients
submitting things.
So I happen to have these
two playlists right now.
I also have the option of
creating a new playlist right
from within here if I have a
brand new initiative on my
website and I want to collect
videos specifically for that.
I could just create a fresh
playlist if I like.
But clicking on one of these
existing playlists will take
me to this initial screen that
will give me the code that I
need for doing things.
I could at this point check out
any pending videos that
have been submitted.
And we see that video, I think
that was from a little bit
earlier today.
Earlier I submitted to a
slightly different playlist.
And at this point I could
watch the video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
So are you having a
good time at I/O?
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
JEFF POSNICK: And as an editor
or moderator of the site, I
could say, OK yes, this is the
sort of thing I want to
feature on a playlist.
Or no, this is not something
I want, say I do
want to approve that.
Click the approve button.
And it's going to end
up showing up in
the approved tab.
So this also gets you
access to all the
previously approved videos.
And you could from here reject
something if you mistakenly
approved it.
And you also have this
rejected tab.
So let me just talk a little bit
more about what the act of
approving a video is.
As I mentioned before, nothing
happens to the original video
that lives in your end-user's
account.
The act of approving a video
will simply add it to a
playlist that you can then
feature on your website.
And there's a nice way of
embedding a playlist player on
your page that will let you show
all the newest video that
have been added to that playlist
without having to
write too much code.
So you can just use our standard
tools that are
already in place for interacting
and displaying
playlists with YouTube
Direct Lite.
So YouTube Direct Lite
is something I'm
really excited about.
But I did want to be upfront
with some limitations and
planned enhancements.
First of all, it's not available
today along with the
upload widget that Eric
was talking about.
We hope to make it available
as soon as possible.
There's a few more things
we need to take care of
internally before releasing
everything.
And that being said, YouTube
Direct Lite is dependent on
CORS, or cross-origin resource
sharing, which I talked about
before and not all browsers
currently support it.
So we're looking into a few
different ways of making that
situation a little bit better.
There are various shims that
you could use that will
provide a fake CORS experience
for browsers that don't quite
yet support it.
Most notably, I think Internet
Explorer 8 and 9 right now
don't support CORS.
But if you are looking to
include YouTube Direct Lite
right now on your site, just be
aware that not every single
browser will support it.
Chrome Frame is another option
that we're looking at for
using with some unsupported
browsers to allow them to
actually make CORS requests.
So moderation of the videos, and
the way that you get that
list of pending videos that we
showed earlier, works via
searches for specific keywords
in public videos.
So you can only submit
public videos.
And there can sometimes
be a delay before a
video is picked up.
So we're doing basically a
YouTube API search for a
specific tag.
And that tag associates
it with a playlist.
And our search index
can lag sometimes.
Normal operation's usually a few
minutes before something
gets submitted and winds up
showing in the search results.
There can be times where it's a
little bit longer that that.
So you should keep
that in mind.
There's not going to be an
instantaneous action between
somebody submitting a video
and when it appears in the
administrative interface.
Finally, we have those existing
open source iOS and
entry clients that allow people
with mobile phones to
record directly from their
phones and upload the video to
YouTube and at the same
time submit it to a
YouTube Direct instance.
We've not yet updated those
clients to talk to YouTube
Direct Lite.
It's a fairly simple change
that I have on a task of
things I need to do.
So I think that will be
something we'll be able to
provide but it's not
quite there yet.
So that's the material that
we wanted to cover.
We have our YouTube for
Developers site that I
encourage everybody to check
out at YouTube.com/dev.
If you haven't been there yet,
there's lots of resources for
YouTube Direct developers, for
folks who are interested soon
in the YouTube embedded upload
widget, and anything else
related to the YouTube API.
I encourage everybody to
circle us on Google+.
We have our YouTube for
Developers account now.
And there's a link right there
that you can use to add us to
your circles and get the latest
information about
things such as when our widgets
are launching and when
YouTube Direct Lite
will be available.
So that being said, I wanted to
open things up right now to
the audience.
Anybody who has any questions
about the material we covered
today or anything really related
to the YouTube APIs,
feel free to come up to
microphones and speak as
loudly and clearly as possible
and hopefully we'll be able to
answer your questions.
Yes.
So we have some great
giveaways for
folks who have questions.
We have quite a few of those.
And JJ, my colleague, is I
think going to hopefully
assist with giving away
things for folks
who've asked questions.
That's a little incentive.
ABNER: Hey, I'm Abner,
from Deja.
And I have a question about
the moderation tool.
Is it only open to my YouTube
user account or can this work
as a way for people to submit
stuff from search results and
stuff like that?
Can they search and submit
something using
the Direct Lite API?
JEFF POSNICK: No, not as
it's written right now.
That might be something that
would require a more heavy,
involved YouTube Direct
platform.
And that's probably a
customization to the open
source code that you
can make to that.
It's not really the intended
use case that we had for
either YouTube Direct or
YouTube Direct Lite.
It's really submitting videos
that are in your own account.
But you will get a T-shirt and
probably confer with JJ
regarding your size.
Any other questions
from the audience?
AUDIENCE: I'll probably
have a few.
I just need to look
at my laundry
list of things I wrote--
[INAUDIBLE]
JEFF POSNICK: Cool.
OK.
Well, we'll be around so feel
free to come to us afterwards.
But thanks everybody for coming
out today and enjoy the
rest of your I/O experience.